mate come on give me a Mazzoli I think
that's Sam's Tower
it's definitely Sam's Tower come on this
way
on me miserly excuse me
mmm excusing what how long you think
before rape gets here let's not stick
around to find out
come on down here Nate sorry pal
thank you
I'm good
vote up I'll take that
let's cut through here doesn't plan yet
Oh real blast
put it steady
way to go Sully still got it
come on right
huh
you're good great
how do we get the sand you just keep
heading downhill brilliant [ __ ] hang on
oh Christ
get out of the way whoa stepdad truck
again please don't run anyone over sorry
you know you don't have me a gym fit I'm
doing my best
we gotta shake that truck working on it
look amazing well just keep em down come
on where the hell are you going down
this was really a great idea mate do you
wanna drive are you doing just fine see
I got it okay through here blue stop
that bad come on get out of here
okay go
ah I'm just gonna cut through here
my supposed to do now hey I've got
stairs here we go watch this out of the
picture you think ah I think we lost him
hey yeah we can never ever come back to
this city add it to the list
yeah well we'll watch it ha ha
really you got a 4x4 go around hang on
sorry fellas first time driver here yeah
we'll be out of your way in a second
let's see that truck I don't got this
oh [ __ ] we're closed keep an eye out for
Sam hey I think that's him right there
all right what do you think I've been
doing
pommie Getchell damned if I know keep
following that convoy
a senator blooms after well
it's
sorry about the chickens
Hey
come on
we are see any way to get this down not
yet
and I don't
hey take a wheel yeah
oh crap crap crap
Oh
[ __ ] me
- it
nice
Oh
enough for this [ __ ]
Oh
hi brother
get closer I'm trying
okay okay come on Sam get in the goddamn
car I'm faster stop arguing watch out
get out of here
not women wait goodness about their
white John that's not good
Oh
here take this
good
I am
ha
the clothes
yeah Shh yeah you're good yeah
I think the coast is clear yeah all
right produce corn essentia this looks
like a simple cipher for God in Liberty
means there Dan motto all the paradise
references keep every mystic see you two
made it out okay
way better than okay you found live
Italia little flipper what're you
Battaglia seems Avery founded the
legendary pirate carny I more about a
pirate utopia really okay what about the
treasure see as the story goes this
place provided a safe haven for hundreds
maybe even thousands of pirates and they
they shared everything property
resources money and they kept it all in
one common treasury building okay so
where is this commie pirate sanctuary
right here
that Island just northeast of Kings Bay
The Rave has a copy of this
yeah well by the time Ray figures it out
we'll be well on our way to liberate
alia Tanya that treasure is as good as
ours
[ __ ] how's the Malaysia job going Nate
seems like you're a hair off course
you
Spencer